Daniel robai was born on January 17 1865
at 600 p.m. at the Esplanade Plantation
in New Orleans he was the son of two
slaves theab be and wendale robotti but
slavery was abolished just 2 weeks after
his birth after the American Civil War
his father wendale made a considerable
Fortune after designing a device used to
mass-produce shoes so Daniel was sent to
all of the best schools and grew up in
what was known as polite Society he
developed a prodigious Talent as an
artist and in his adulthood many other
wealthy people hired him to create
portraits for them which were meant to
document their wealth and be a sign of
their position in society one of these
commissions came from a wealthy
landowner named Hayward Sullivan who
hired Daniel to capture his daughter's
virginal Beauty as he puts it her name
was Caroline Sullivan and the only
problem with this job is that her beauty
did not stay virginal for very long they
fell in love and in 1890 Caroline became
pregnant which was a big problem for her
father who is still transfixed by the
legacy of slavery after slavery ended
there was still a period of racial
segregation so Mr Sullivan believed it
was wrong for his white daughter to have
a relationship with a black man this was
a hot button issue at the time it was
the same year that robotized home state
of Louisiana passed the Separate Car Act
which required separate but equal train
cars for black and white passengers and
this was just four years before the
specific issue of interracial marriage
would be addressed when it would be
outright prohibited in the state but
because there was no legal recourse at
the time Caroline's father hired some
men to hunt robai down and told them to
get creative with the punishment they
finally tracked him down in an area in
Chicago Illinois that would eventually
become known as Cabrini Green I'm not
sure why Daniel and Caroline were living
there when both are from New Orleans but
it stands the reason that Caroline's
father was such a wealthy land owner
that he had land in multiple States
whatever the reason may be Daniel robai
was caught by the men and they proceeded
to saw off his right hand and smear his
body with honey stolen from a local
apiary people in town had gathered
around to watch the torture and one kid
takes a taste from the honeycomb with
his finger resulting in the coining of
robot's iconic nickname Candyman and the
whole crowd just starts chanting
Candyman over and over this is also the
origin of one of candyman's often
repeated catchphrases sweet the sweet
the L actually comes from William
Shakespeare's Hamlet at the funeral of
Hamlet's love interest opilia oia's
mother is scattering flowers on her
daughter's grave when she says the line
so this woman saying it during the
lynching of Candyman is doing so in a
mocking way and that's when the huge
swarm of bees located their stolen
honeycomb and furiously attacked the man
covered in their honey robai was stung
to death by the beads but it's said that
Caroline's pain was even greater than
his own he promises that his captors
will all be damned as her father
contemptuously holds her mirror up to
his face to show him the monstrosity
that he had become claiming Caroline
wouldn't even look at him now Daniel
robot's last words are Candyman as he
passes away while staring into the
mirror but something happened that day
and when Caroline retrieves the mirror
she sees his soul captured inside of it
Witnesses said the lynching was so
agonizing that his soul was trapped
inside the mirror this man couldn't lash
out in life but in death that that hate
that evil was strong enough to bring him
back to reclaim what was taken away
Sullivan's men then burned his body on a
giant p and Scattered his ashes around
the area Caroline still honored Ed his
memory at a maum in their home state
inscribing the words my beloved may you
suffer no more but this turned out to be
anything but the case his resurrection
began as rumor and grew into
myth say his name five times in the
mirror he would appear the myth has
traveled from place to place taking root
in the most desperate areas his last
name actually references the virally
spreading stories and rumors about his
Legend robotti is a French word meaning
bright and famous to learn learn how
candyman's tale inspired a slew of
similar Legends the true story of
Candyman from our world and the often
overlooked true meaning of Candyman
stick around to the end of this video
this video is sponsored by rocket
[Music]
money I am the writing on the wall The
Whisper In The Horror history classroom
welcome to another episode by the way
finally a Horror history episode that
isn't about a robot or a clown Candyman
originated in a 1985 short story called
The Forbidden by Clive Barker one year
before making the Nolla that went on to
become Hellraiser the story is set in a
decaying housing project in Liverpool
England where the protagonist Helen is
researching urban legends for her thesis
yeah take a seat in the Horror history
classroom Helen she stumbles upon the
legend of Candyman who becomes a
menacing and deadly presence the story
tackles themes about folklore ability to
take a life of its own and fittingly he
seems to be a combination of real urban
legends like Bloody Mary and the hookman
in 1992 director Bernard Rose adapted
the story to film this time being set in
Chicago transforming The Original
Stories themes about the British class
system to issues of racial segregation
in the ghetto just as the legend of the
Candyman grew through various retellings
of the story in the movie The Character
expanded through pop culture in our
world with the release of three sequels
Candyman farewell to the Flesh in 1995
Candyman Day of the Dead in 1999 and
Candyman 2021 because subtitles are so
out in the 2020s the actual chronology
gets a little more confusing than that
but of course I will be sorting all of
that out in this video outside of the
cannon the character has become kind of
the face of urban legends in General
being parodied in South Park Biggy
Smalls Biggy Smalls Biggy
Smalls what the [__] is
[Music]
this and receiving the honor of being
the Epic closer to ice 9 kills silver
Scream 2
album a single listen will guarantee
that you'll get hooked but to fully
understand the buzz surrounding the
Candyman we've got to take it back to
the legends that inspired his
creation
[Music]
Candyman began appearing to anyone who
dared say his name five times into the
mirror not just Caroline's mirror but
any mirare when he appeared his severed
hand would be replaced by a sharp hook
and he would be covered in bees just as
he had in his final moments these
elements bring to mind a number of real
world urban Legends Bloody Mary is an
English myth based on Queen Mary the
first who ruled in the 1500s and
executed over 200 Protestants during her
Reign earning her the infamous nickname
Legend has it that if you stare into a
mirror alone with only a candle's light
and recite the name and Bloody Mary
three times you'll see her spirit appear
in the mirror behind you there are many
different versions of the story thanks
to narrative drifts so if you've heard a
version where you have to say the name
13 times or a version where the ghost is
actually that of a woman who committed
suicide that's probably why candyman's
story also gets skewed by multiple
retellings over time in fact other than
that there are a number of other
similarities with Candyman the obvious
one is the summoning by mirror
recitation but one of the reasons that
Bloody Mary is so popular at sleepovers
is because sometimes the person
performing the ritual really does see
Bloody Mary or at at least psychologists
think they did staring at a dimly lit
mirror for an extended period of time
can lead to something known as strange
face Illusions this is a phenomenon
that's really been tested and confirmed
in 58% of patients it could be a
combination of face parodia or the
ability for our brains to see faces in
everyday objects and the power of belief
if the person really believes that
they're going to see Bloody Mary in the
mirror then they might actually
hallucinate something whatever the case
the result is that only the person in
front of the mirror will be able to see
her and Candyman is treated in a similar
way using this to his advantage to
psychologically manip iate his victims
there's also the fact that Queen Mary's
portrait is kind of freaky and goes
unnecessarily hard much like candyman's
self-portrait the other urban legend
that seems to have inspired the Candyman
Mythos is the hookman a killer with a
hook for a hand who attacks people in
parked cars the hookman is often
depicted in a rain code giving him a
similar silhouette to the Candyman who
can be seen wearing this big loow
hanging fur coat of course the names are
also similar if you want to put any
stock into that hookman and Candyman but
Candyman is less about adapting and
changing existing Legends and more about
how hysteria gives birth to new ones
shortly after Daniel robotized lynching
in 1890 his lover Caroline would give
birth to a daughter Isabelle begning the
lineage that would span for many
generations if there's anything that
scares me more than the various urban
legends that I've discussed up to this
point it's seeing extra money coming out
of my bank account I recently discovered
that I was being charged twice for the
same subscription this very well could
have broken me financially but luckily I
teamed up with rocket money to sponsor
this video rocket money is the personal
finance app that helps you cancel
subscriptions lower bills and better
manage your money I love using rocket
money because it's too easy for me to
get caught up in making content and not
realize how much money I could be saving
canceling unwanted subscriptions is easy
the app automatically identifies
recurring subscriptions and makes it
easy to cancel an app with just a couple
tasks rocket money has helped save its
customers an average of $720 a year with
over 500 million in canceled
subscriptions the app also has other
features like smart budgeting which will
analyze your spending habits and create
a custom budget that works with your
lifestyle it will automatically monitor
your spending by category and notify you
when you've exceeded your limit you can
get started for free so there's no
reason not to try this out and make sure
that your finances are in shape just go
to Rocket money.com seworld to get
started that's rocket money.com czworld
to take control of your finances
[Music]
today Daniel robai was not the only
person to find himself incorporated into
the Candyman Mythos after the end of
slavery in the United States racism and
segregation continued to rear its ugly
head in 1922 a man named William Bell
was arrested Under Suspicion of
attacking a white woman and was was
lynched by an angry mob before he got to
trial this is a real thing that happened
there's even a memorial for him but in
the 2021 movie William is mentioned as
one of four men whose pain was
incorporated into the Candyman legend
it's possible that William was not
actually summoned as a spirit like the
others but rather was just
metaphorically represented by Candyman
this guy at first implies that Candyman
is just a madeup legend that represents
the tragedies that have occurred due to
Prejudice basically that people created
Candyman to cope with all of the
violence so that they could have
something to blame but eventually it
becomes clear that there are other
Spirits outside of Daniel Roby that can
be summoned by saying candyman's name so
in Williams case we don't know for sure
shortly after a neighborhood of
two-story row houses was built in
Chicago and the area became known as
Cabrini Green in 1942 the name Cabrini
Green makes it sound like some kind of
paradise with grass and trees but that
was anything but the case it's actually
a combination of two last names Francis
Cabrini and William green Cabrini Green
became a ghetto and it was set up in
such a way that it was cut off from the
wealthier sections of town got the
highway and the L train to keep the
ghetto cut off Cabrini Green is almost
an architectural extension of these
segregation that began the Candyman
legend in the first place Daniel Roby
was forced to separate from his white
lover and the residents of Cabrini Green
were being a geographically separated
from the rest of the city the next
Candyman would face similar
discrimination his name was Samuel Evans
and it said that he was run down during
the white housing riots in the 1950s as
far as I can tell Samuel Evans is
fictional but the events being referred
to here are based on a series of real
events the most well-known was the
Cicero race riot of 1951 basically this
huge mob went crazy all because this one
black family was moving into to an
apartment building and the Illinois
National Guard had to be called in again
all of the conflict is centered around
segregation in 1957 the mid-rises and
high rises were built in Cabrini Green
and quickly became a symbol of very poor
living conditions and crime and this
would be where whispers about the
Candyman really started to take off it
would be difficult to say for sure how
many were killed by the vengeful spirit
because again Candyman was both a real
dangerous Ghost with the ability to kill
those who summoned him and a metaphor
and scapegoat for inner city violence in
general if there was an unsolved murder
in kabini green it was often blamed on
Candyman regardless of whether or not
the ghost of Daniel Roby was responsible
from 1942 to 1987 21 such incidents were
attributed to Candyman according to
local newspapers in 1977 we got our
fourth Candyman a man named Sherman
Fields here hook for a hand neighborhood
character used to stand out there and
hand out sweet St when I was a kid I
know Sherman was maybe just trying to be
a nice guy by handing out candy but
maybe just maybe if you live in a
neighborhood haunted by a vengeful
Spirit named The Candy Man and you just
so happen to have a hook for a hand just
like Candyman maybe it's not the
smartest idea to go around handing out
sweets one October a razor blade shows
up in a little white girl's Halloween
candy police come around here looking
for Sherman but Sherman's gone Sherman
must have known that this was not a good
look for him and began hiding out in the
walls of the apartment complex where he
became a bit of an urban legend himself
among the neighborhood kids I hope
Sherman gets and one October morning he
emerges from a hole in the wall of the
laundry room and off offers candy to a
boy named William which I'm not saying
he deserved what happened to him but he
has to realize that coming out of a wall
and offering candy in the area known as
Candyman country is kind of creepy due
to the stories young William seems to
agree that it's creepy and he screams
and Sherman is caught and beaten to
death by police but like robati and
presumably the others before him he was
innocent and his soul is intertwined in
the Candyman folklore his name
disappeared from the stories over the
years and he was simply known as
Candyman and when William's sister
eventually called Candyman name he was
the one to take revenge on her it may
seem like it's getting kind of confusing
since we now have four different people
who are all known as Candyman but if you
think about it this tends to be how real
urban legends go as the story is passed
from generation to generation details
get changed and bias from each time
period Creeps in it's not that different
from the Legend of Bloody Mary depending
on who you ask today people might tell
you that Bloody Mary is one of a number
of people including Queen Mary the first
of England an American serial killer
named Mary worth Hungarian serial killer
c as Elizabeth ba or even a Salem witch
trial victim named Mary from the early
modern era I honestly don't know how
Elizabeth B's name got in the mix
because her name isn't even Mary it
might just be one of those things where
two different urban legends merge with
the passage of time much like Sherman
fields and Daniel robati also quick
timeline note about Sherman fields at
one point there was an article claiming
that he died in 1970 but I'd have to
trust the title card that claims it was
1977 the title card is always all
knowing and to back this up there's a
flyer at an art gallery that claims that
it happened in the late '70s this may be
a continuity error but I choose to at it
as another example of the nature of
folklore as retellings continually
reshape a story you end up with
different versions that have different
details we see the same effect happened
all the time in the news today I
recently watched a video from a Creator
named upper echelon where he compares
the modern news cycle to the children's
game telephone in telephone you start
with one phrase and each kid Whispers it
to the kid next to them and once you get
all the way around the circle the
original phrase is often changed
entirely and in his video he talks about
how the same thing is happening with
news Publishers writing articles and
other news Publishers articles and then
journalists getting their info
secondhand from those articles etc etc
and you end up with the original
statement being completely changed or
exaggerated due to the bias in how each
writer interprets the message of the
previous writer so the same thing seems
to be going on in Candyman in 1981
Philip Purcell an anthropology professor
at University of Illinois Chicago or UIC
for short wrote a paper on Candyman
which didn't exactly help the Legend die
at some points most likely in the mid
80s a gang leader started terrorizing
the neighborhood calling himself
Candyman while we don't know exactly
what his motivation was I imagine that
he thought some non- Skeptics would come
to believe that the angry Spirit of
Daniel robai was the one committing his
heinous crimes and that's essentially
what happened on the particularly
disturbing April 22
1987 all I know was there was some lady
in a tub and and she heard a noise I
think her name was Ruthie Jean when
Ruthie jeene called the police they
didn't believe her giving ample time for
the gangster to break into her apartment
through the medicine cabinet that
conjoined her bathroom to the vacant
unit next to hers she was later found to
have been killed with a hook and if that
idea isn't disquieting enough it may not
bring you any comfort to learn that this
actually
[Music]
happened Ruthie May McCoy was a real
woman who was killed in Chicago after a
man came in through her medicine cabinet
and she was the inspiration for the
identical crime that took place in the
original 1992 film Candyman Ruthie
McCoy's name was kind of split into two
characters Ruth jeene the woman who was
killed in her apartments and anarie
McCoy her neighbor who later faces some
horrors of her own at the expense of her
infant son Ruthie May McCoy also had
schizophrenia in Candyman the
protagonist Helen is made to look like
she has schizophrenia by Candyman to
hide his involvement and make her look
guilty this creates a direct link
between the mental illness and the
Candyman Mythos in real life police
didn't believe Ruthie when she called
911 because they knew she had
schizophrenia but in the movie they
didn't believe her because they didn't
believe in Candyman a reporter for the
Chicago Reader discovered that b cabinet
break-ins were quite common and well
known by residents of the Abbott Homes
apartments where McCoy lived apparently
the bathroom cabinets had been installed
backto back with a 2ft wide pipe Chase
running between the apartments they were
Loosely attached to the walls with just
six flimsy nails to make it easy for
plumbers to access the pipes for repairs
the newspaper in Candyman tells an
almost identical story with of course a
few key details changed the killer or
killers of Ruthie jeene smashed their
way through the back of the medicine
cabinet in the small apartment bathroom
the attack took place at the Cabrini
Green housing project this mysterious
attack brings the total of unsolved
murders in the housing project to an
alarming 26 just this year it's
interesting how the headline says what
killed Ruthie jeene and not who killed
Ruthie Jee while the gangster posing as
Candyman built fear in the community
without summoning the real thing the
legend was also alive and well outside
of kabini green one particularly
chilling example happened in the late '
80s maybe 1988 happened a few years ago
near Moses Lake in Indiana a babysitter
named Clara is visited by a guy she has
a hotpor named Billy and challenges him
to try summoning Candyman but stops him
short of saying his name the fifth time
after he goes downstairs she for unknown
reasons completes the ritual by reciting
the name for the fifth time Candyman
when she turned off the lights she saw
him standing there behind her her blood
leaked through the ceiling and Candyman
killed the baby too Billy survived but
his hair turned white from shock this
brings up a few questions about the
rules around summoning Candyman in this
instance we learn a few things number
one it doesn't have to be the same
person saying the name each time whoever
says it the fifth and final time will be
considered the Summoner and that be the
person who faces his wrath number two
there doesn't appear to be a time limit
you can pause as long as you want
between each Candyman which people love
to do there's always a ridiculous
dramatic pause before saying it for the
final time in fact the five Declarations
of the name don't even have to be
consecutive you can interrupt the ritual
with other dialogue but the samei name
counter doesn't stop around this time
there was also another story involving a
handicapped boy who was killed by
Candyman in a public restroom in cabrina
green while his mom was chopping across
the street when a man went in to check
on him it said that his hair also turned
white this boy was most likely a victim
of the gangster posing as Candyman not
the supernatural Candyman himself then
there's the most notable victim a
graduate student at UIC named Helen L
kabini green Chicago
1992 yeah I'm going to ignore this
newspaper headline from 1991 and assume
that the guy who wrote a book on
Candyman has his dates correct 1992 it
is Helen and her classmate bernardet are
working on a project on urban legends
she's also married to a professor Trevor
who teaches a class on Modern folklore
on the board you can see some of the
common elements that he's identif in
neighborhood Legends some if only a
little basis in truth often a victim
seeking Revenge resides in a forbidden
area sometimes to keep children from the
area this is also probably a reference
to the original short story and
deformities and appliances blades hooks
Etc these are obviously all traits that
applying to the Candyman legend but he
sees these urban legends as more of a
reflection of societal fears rather than
a supernatural phenomenon which is
basically what Candyman is in our world
we have a term for that here in Horror
history cultural Legend ising Candyman
is a metaphor for racial segregation in
the same way that Godzilla represents
nuclear fallout the demagorgon
represents fears of Communism and Larona
represents issues in Central American
marriage practices see these stories
are modern oral folklore they are the
unselfconscious reflection of the fears
of urban society as part of her research
Helen talks to a woman familiar with the
story of Ruthie jeene and when Candyman
is brought up she becomes visibly
uncomfortable she eventually discovers
that her own apartment was originally
supposed to be a housing project with
the same layout as the building in
Cabrini Green and after replacing her
mirror her and bernardet recite the
illicit name into it four times but
notably only Helen completes the ritual
by saying the fit after a 4-second pause
for dramatic effect of course however
Candyman does not act against Helen
immediately the next day they go to
visit the actual apartment where Ruthie
Gene lost her life in Cabrini Green and
they're instantly spotted and suspected
to be policed by the locals they
discover graffiti referencing the
original Legend and a huge painting of
robotti in what's left of Ruthie Jean's
former apartment she also finds a pile
of candy one of which contains a razor
blade could this mean that someone in
the building is the actual Criminal Who
Framed Sherman Fields I think that may
be the case Fields passed away in 1977
and Ruthie Jean's apartment wouldn't
have been vacated until 10 years later
meaning that this candy was placed here
well after his death this is where
Candyman first approaches Helen however
she doesn't realize it until later when
reviewing the photos on the way out they
meet a woman named anarie McCoy who
explains that she heard Ruthie screaming
through the wall the night of the murder
and dialed 911 but nobody came and Marie
claims that she's scared for her son
because they're never going to catch
Candyman Helen would later go back alone
and meet a boy named Jake who refuses to
talk out of fear that the Candyman will
get it he does however lead her to the
bathroom where the other young boy was
once killed she finds more sweets to the
Sweet graffiti and all of the toilets
are destroyed except for the last one
which is completely filled with beads
she doesn't know it yet but this is the
first hallucination that she's seeing as
a result of candyman's influence
actually I'm not sure if Hallucination
is the right word when someone summons
the Candyman he or she can see the
spirit and the colony of bees that come
with it but others cannot however
they're not hallucinations candyman's
hook really can Pierce and the bees
really can sting one thing that is
definitely not a hallucination or Spirit
of any kind is the gang leader who's
been going around calling himself
Candyman and when he shows up and traps
her in the bathroom it's bad news for
Helen Lyle she's lucky to survive his
attack but one silver lining is that the
police are finally able to arrest the
man who killed Ruthie jeene nobody was
willing to testify against him until now
once he's arrested belief in the
Candyman around Cabrini Green reaches an
alltime low which prompts him to finally
make his presence known to Helen as
she's reviewing photos in the university
parking lot do I know you no but you
doubted
me once Helen realizes who he really is
Candyman explains that he was obliged to
come because she didn't believe in the
Legends I am the writing on the wall the
whisper in the classroom with without
these things I am nothing so now I must
shed innocent blood essentially he's
saying that he must continue to kill in
order to keep his Legend alive but
contrary to what you would expect based
on his behavior so far he doesn't kill
Helen instead she wakes up in the
bathroom back at an Marie's apartment
where she finds the dog beheaded and the
baby Anthony missing before long police
storm in and apprehend her so why does
Candyman frame her instead of just
killing her this will become more
evident throughout his story but I think
Candyman sees something in Helen that
reminds him of his love from 1890
Caroline he doesn't just want to kill
Helen he wants her to join him but we'll
get into that a little bit later after
she's bailed out of jail he appears to
her again by punching through her
medicine
cabinets this method of Entry is
symbolic it's the same way that Ruthie
Jean's apartment was invaded 4 years ago
he's getting back at her for making
people believe that Candyman isn't real
your disbelief destroy the faith of my
congregation it's interesting how he
references his followers as his
congregation ation giving it a religious
undertone it's not the only religious
parallel I noticed his outfit almost
makes it look as if he's wearing clergy
robes and non- diagetic the gospel music
that we hear when he's around makes it
feel as if he's constantly being
followed by a church choir there will be
more religious references but I think
the main takeaway is that he's being
used to show the similarities between
organized religion and urban legends
both are supported by the belief of the
congregation Candyman makes Helen an
offer giving the option for an Marie's
baby to die in her place that's when her
friend bernardet arrives lets herself in
and is shocked to come face to face with
Candyman who rips her apart casting
further guilt on Helen when her husband
comes home and finds the Carnage Helen
is committed to an insane asylum and on
the way there he speaks to her again
trying to convince her that she's better
off trying to gain immortality by
becoming an urban legend herself to be
whispered about its street corners to
live in other people's dreams but not to
have to be she also has visions of where
he's hidden the baby and praise to God
not to let him kill it again we're
seeing the contrast in her religion with
which she has no trouble accepting due
to her social background and Candyman
something she initially didn't believe
in which is what landed her in this mess
in the first place at the hospital she's
tied down with armor strains and robotti
floats above her where some of his
motivation starts to come out what do
the good know except what the bad teach
them by their excesses allow me at least
to
kiss just one
Exquisite kiss this is more evidence
that Helen has become a standin for
Caroline Sullivan the line almost sound
sounds like something that robai might
have said to Caroline in the beginning
of their romance he knew that the
relationship would be forbidden because
of society's views towards interracial
relationships in the 1800s but he's
trying to convince her to give him just
that one kiss Helen tries crying for
help but nobody else can see Candyman
which makes it look like she's
schizophrenic she ends up sedated on
Thorazine completely unaware of the
passage of time and we can see Candyman
keeping the baby alive during this time
by feeding him what I assume is honey
from the tip of his finger a month goes
by before Helen is finally woken up
again and for the first time she
demonstrates her full belief in Candyman
by attempting to summon him using the
side mirror in an attempt to prove that
he really exists and she's not crazy
before saying Candyman for the final
time she pauses 11 seconds for dramatic
effect although Candyman does appear he
doesn't do her any favors in proving her
innocence as she had hoped because he
shows up and tears through her
psychologist with the hook but again he
doesn't come after her instead cutting
off her restraints and flying out
through the window giving her the
opportunity to escape and flee home
where she finds her husband has already
replaced her with a younger woman from
one of his classes although Candyman
doesn't appear during this interaction I
still find it relevant to mention
because it's another example of the
rumors and Whispers becoming reality she
had previously suspected Trevor of
having an affair but never fully
believed it to be true with nowhere else
to go she sneaks back to Cabrini Green
to reinvestigate the vacant apartment
one more time and finds his layer
illuminated in candl light this time she
climbs up to another room and finds
Candyman sleeping in the ruins she
attempts to attack him with the hook she
found but he jolts awake and demands
that she surrender herself if she wants
to save the baby surrender to me now and
he shall be unharmed there are
definitely some uh undertones to the way
that he says surrender as he Strokes her
face which is somehow now covered in
makeup this doesn't make any sense
because she wouldn't be wearing makeup
after having awoken from one month of
sedation in the psych War the way this
is shot almost resembles an old Romance
movie so I think it's all part of her
transformation into the replacement for
Caroline after laying her down she
discovers her hand covered with bees and
he opens his robe to reveal his decaying
torso playing home to an entire swarm
they pour out of his mouth as he kisses
her which is one of the more disturbing
things ever when you consider that there
was no CGI used for this after their
encounter he places the baby in the
middle of a huge pile up outside that
was going to be used for a bonfire and
leaves behind a message for Helen over
the portraits depicting its execution a
century ago it says it was always you
Helen which I interpret as the strongest
evidence that he's using her to fill the
void left by Caroline a cope 100 years
in the makan hearing the screams of the
baby Helen climbs into the pile up and
Jake the boy who helped her before sees
the hook that she's holding and assumes
that it's candy m
he's here this prompts the neighborhood
kids to dowe the pile in gasoline and
began the fire and everyone gathers
around hoping to watch the evil that has
long haunted their Community burn Helen
does make it to the baby but Candyman
appears behind her and attempts to trap
her in the fire she's able to reach a
burning Spike and jam it into his chest
he screams and thrashes as the structure
around them crumbles but Helen is able
to power her way out with the baby and
deliver him back to his mother before
finally succumbing to her burns the
Candyman Goes Up in Flames and explodes
into an eruption of Sparks and judging
by the sound bead that would be the last
we'd see of him in 1992 the religious
subtext is referenced one more time as
the entire neighborhood visits Helen at
her funeral demonstrating how they see
her as a hero now and their belief in
Candyman is restored they all vow to
never say his name again but allegedly
someone broke the paack and given how
many people know about Candyman at this
point it was very unlikely that this
would even do anything there's always
got to be that one kid who runes it for
the class Helen also incarnates into a
vengeful Spirit of her own but that
doesn't really connect to candy man
going forward but at some point the
anthropology Professor Purcell writes a
book on all of this called Candyman A
Century of fear and he goes on tour with
it prompting even more people to try
reciting the cursed
name other than Cabrini Green in Chicago
one of the most popular locations that
the legend is festered in is Daniel
robot's birthplace in New Orleans
Louisiana where in true Bourbon Street
fashion in the early '90s he would leave
four people laying face down in the
gutter only in this case they were dead
not drunk it would appear that prell's
book inspired them all to test their
luck by saying his name into the mirror
the first three victims faces were so
mutilated that they went unidentified by
police the fourth was Mr Coleman tant
who happened to be part of robotized
family tree if you'll recall Daniel and
Caroline had a daughter named Isabelle
she went on to have a daughter whose
name we don't know and her daughter was
named Octavia Octavia married Coleman
and had two kids Annie tant and Ethan
tant we don't know exactly when Coleman
got the hook from Candyman only that he
got involved in the trafficking of
stolen art on the black market as part
of an attempt to obtain Caroline
Sullivan's mirror this was the same
mirror that roboti Soul was trapped in
and he believed breaking it would break
the curse and Destroy Candyman forever
however he was too late and his son
Ethan found him sacrificed in front of
the Candyman painting in their old attic
anyway during Purcell's book tour he
shows a slide on Helen Lyle who is now
the latest chapter this article appears
next to a story titled fleeing militants
Bangladeshi writer arrives in Sweden
this is a real article from The New York
Times which was published on August 11
1994 meaning that the New Orleans stop
on Purcell's book tour must have been
after that more specifically on February
25th 1995 because the following day is
stated to be 3 days until lent and it's
only a couple of days until Marty gr one
other note about this article the
newspaper States many believe she was
killed by killer beats Purcell's
official version of the story also
differs from what actually happened
Helen ly becomes so obsessed by the myth
that she takes on on the Persona of
Candyman killing her victims with a hook
as part of a gag to entertain his
audience Purcell says Candyman five
times into the reflective book cover
with a 5-second dramatic pause before
the finale although the crowd is
startled by the actor he hired to tear
through the projector it's not until
late that night after purcel got into a
scuffle with a disgruntled reader that
Candyman strikes making it look like it
was his attacker who came back for more
the man who's blamed for Purcell's
murder is Ethan teron the great great
grandson of Daniel robai from his
perspective his dad was killed by
Candyman after reading Purcell's book
leading him to feel that Purcell is
partially responsible Ethan is arrested
and despite his attempts to stop his
sister Annie from investigating the
story she probes their childhood home
for Clues and discovers the shrine to
Candyman the next day February 27th the
topic comes up in the school that she
teaches at and she like Helen sees
Candyman as a reflection no pun intended
of societal fears sometimes there are
people in this world that do bad things
horrible things and when they don't get
caught we start blaming imaginary
monsters for their crimes but that's all
the candy man is an imaginary monster
and by the way Annie is an art teacher a
direct reflection of robai who is a
professional artist in order to prove to
her students that he isn't real she says
his name five times in the mirror making
a dramatic 9-second pause before the
final repetition she boasts that nothing
happened but one of her students notices
a bee continually flying out the window
which doesn't put him at e that night
she's in the bathroom cleaning up when
she switches off the light and she comes
face to face with Candyman for the first
time he repeats the same lines he used
on Helen but this time tells her that he
cares for her and that they have a
journey to make together that's when he
disappears into the other room and tears
his hook straight through her husband's
torso she foolishly tries to retaliate
by scratching him on the face but this
just works against her because it opens
this crevice which the bees start
crawling out of she's unable to escape
the apartment without him appearing
before her So eventually just like Helen
she passes out her experience with
Candyman is somewhat different though
he's not trying to mold her into his
next lover because she's his great great
granddaughter and that would be weird if
something like that were to happen now
or in the future
future but he's still going to use her
to make people fear his name once more
the urban legend versus religion
comparison is also back as Annie heads
home from the police station after
giving her testimony she sees religious
protesters her entire investigation into
her father's death is set in the
backdrop of Carnival which is a festive
season in Christianity that occurs in
the days leading up to Ash Wednesday
which marks the beginning of land it's
celebrated with parades music and Street
parties with many mass attendees hiding
their true identity in this story it
serves as a parallel to Annie's family
history as she works to uncover the
secrets of her relation to Daniel robai
which has been hidden or some might say
masked by her mother who is ashamed of
that part of their lineage and perhaps
because of this she sees clues in her
encounters with Candy Man Dan the
following day is marra also known as Fat
Tuesday and she sees dreams or visions
of robai coming for her mom's throat one
of her students Matthew goes missing and
when she visits his neighborhood to
offer help she gets a lot of weird looks
and hostility not unlike what Helen
experienced in Cabrini Green it's a sign
of the distrust created by the legacy of
segregation she finally speaks to the
boy father a pastor who explains that
Matthew had been having nightmares
leading him to stay up all night
painting these kind of creepy pictures
of robai and his lynching the pastor
refers to Candyman Believers as turning
to a false god adding that he never
thought that his son actually believed
the stories when asked about the
possibility that he really exists he
doesn't offer much optimism and only God
can save us Annie continues to search
for information about her father's final
days leading her to the French Quarter
where she learns about his Conquest to
find Caroline Sullivan's mirror but this
too is interrupted by a Candyman attack
leaving behind another body covered in
betins Annie tries reasoning with the
hook-handed hasher asking what he wants
and that's when he explains that Annie
has a daughter growing inside of her and
offers a cryptic clue you cannot change
the you are she hasn't figured out that
they're related yet so she just runs for
it with Candyman continuing to appear to
her at various points in the parade
meanwhile at the police station one of
the cops tries to get answers out of
Ethan the officer attempts to summon the
Candyman in order to prove that he's not
real one of the classic blunders in the
Candyman franchise his hesitation before
saying Candyman for the the fifth time
is the best in the series only 1 second
however his lack of hesitation doesn't
do him any good and the cop is thrown
through a second story window which has
got to be the most epic kill in
candyman's history out of fear Ethan
tries to escape and he ends up getting
shot down by police however this time
there is security camera footage that
kind of proves that Ethan was innocent
and convinces at least one detective
that Candyman is responsible because we
see the cop lifted into the air and torn
apart by an invisible force
unfortunately we don't know what becomes
of this tape such as if it ever gets out
and seen by the public if it did it
could be used to change the narrative
behind Helen Lyle and many other
Candyman attacks that have yet to happen
belief is always the biggest hurdle and
most of candyman's victims summon him
just to prove that he isn't real so this
video could actually be of great value
however this was 10 years before YouTube
so it's entirely possible that it was
just thrown in an Evidence archive and
forgotten about or maybe it was released
but then people just assumed that it was
staged and it ended up on one of those
shows like Unsolved Mysteries where it
would not be taken seriously I will come
back to this later because I think it's
an important clue for a theory that I
have not brought up yet in this video
just trust me have I ever let you down
don't answer that regardless of what
happens with the tape Annie is about to
find out the truth behind her family
history and it would lead to a spicy
Skirmish boiling over in the bayou and
I'm not talking about the
[Music]
gumbo as Annie confronts her mother
about the picture found in her drawer of
Caroline and Isabelle her great
great-grandmother and great-grandmother
respectively she discovers that her
connection to Daniel robot's bloodline
has been hidden from her for her entire
life your father was trying to destroy
everything that we had by linking our
name with that monster so you destroyed
it
instead by denying the truth I am not a
b of him we're his
family where're his blood I will not
have him talk like that in this house
you can't wash him away with a bottle
there is no
Candyman he does not exist so once again
Candyman is the legend ised version of
racial segregation originally he was the
victim of segregation from his romantic
relationship but even now over a century
later there are still people trying to
distance themselves from their blood
relationships and Octavia is about to
learn that blood is thicker than water
and steel hooks are thicker than an old
woman's back got
him I just wanted to pause right here
because this is one of the most epic
neck tendon clenches I've ever seen I
don't even know if I could do
that that's good acting Annie runs to
her childhood home at the old plantation
searching for Caroline's mirror where
she finally runs into Matthew who had
been hiding out there after seeing
Candyman in his dreams they realize the
mirror must be hidden in the slaves
quarters which Annie has never been to
but before she can grab it Candyman
appears to her one more time warning her
not to touch it the mirror is the secret
of my strength the keeper of my
soul the destiny of our family why would
you tell her that I don't know after
telling her his story he asks her to
join him and go onto a World Without
Pain however she instead goes for the
mirror which seemed to somehow be the
only thing holding the place together
from being ravaged by the storm raging
on outside taking it causes the walls to
collapse and the slave quarters to flood
Annie is rescued by her students but
when she reaches back to grab the mirror
Candyman emerges from the flood and
tells her that the choice is no longer
hers however she smashes the mirror
causing old grandpa Dan to freeze in
place and shatter into pieces leaving
his hook the only remaining Remnant to
clatter to the floor where Helen had
unsuccessfully banished Candyman in
flame Annie seems to find greater
success washing away the curses of his
past in flood this also marks the
beginning of lent in Christianity from
my understanding lent is where you give
something up that you love for 40 days I
remember when I was a kid there would
always be kids who gave up like pizza or
something what a sacrifice while they
were letting go of roughly 300 calories
and Annie's case it's time to let go of
the past however several years later she
would be sure to teach her daughter
about their entire family history
including the interracial Love Story
involving Daniel robai Justice for the
relative who tried to kill you she even
named her daughter Caroline in honor of
her great great great grandmother
personally I have no idea who my great
great great grandparents are and that
seems a little excessive I'm not going
to say if I'll have a kid in the future
or not but if I do end up having great
great great grandchildren and if they
are watching this video in the year 216
all I'm saying is that if your content
sucks then I am going to haunt you I
have worked too hard to bring respect to
this dynasty when young Caroline sees
the mirror on her mobile she
inexplicably starts chanting Candyman
but her mom comes in and stops her
before saying the full phrase and this
symbolically marks the end of the
Candyman cycle like the robotti slave
quarters which were washed away many
other elements of the Legacy start to
crumble the Cabrini Green highrises were
demolished over the course of 1995 to
2011 and replaced with luxury Lofts and
condos though the identity of the
neighborhood was forever changed there
would be one hold over from the past
remember Anthony McCoy no actually you
do or if you don't then you seriously
need to go to the doctor you need to go
to the brain doctor Anthony was the baby
that Candyman abducted in 1992 who was
saved by Helen wild in 2019 a now
27-year-old Anthony has become surprise
surprise an artist one day his
girlfriend's brother tells the story of
Helen Lyall which he's not familiar with
his past has been kept from him by his
mother also we see how the story has
changed over the years with details like
Helen doing snow angels in dog's blood
and her now being painted as the villain
who tried to sacrifice the baby rather
than the hero who saved the baby and was
celebrated by the community at her
funeral on Tuesday May 15th 2019 Anthony
does some research about Cabrini Green
the week days in this universe don't
seem to match up with the weekday in
ours but once again if there's a title
card like this I'm going to take that as
gospel pun definitely intended and I
probably wouldn't use that word if I was
not making the pun while taking a photo
he's stung on the hand by a bee you
could interpr this as a coincidence but
it seems like even though Candyman was
shattered 24 years ago his curse remains
with Anthony years later after meeting
William the kid who screamed at Sherman
Fields Anthony learns about Candyman and
says his name in the mirror just to
freak out his girlfriend he pauses 8
seconds before the final repetition I'm
seriously starting to want these moments
of my life back it's really adding up
after watching every Candyman movie it's
not entirely clear how it works but with
Daniel robai being destroyed this seems
to summon the next man up Sherman fields
or maybe Fields is just summoned because
Anthony was the to call him and that's
the version of the legend that Anthony
is familiar with like if you believe
you're going to see Sherman fields in
the mirror then you'll see Sherman
Fields but if you believe you're going
to see one of the others you'll see one
of the others if that's the case it
could be a depiction of people who see
Bloody Mary because of their own
imagination they believe they're going
to see something and they did Anthony
becomes obsessed with the Candyman
legend and creates a whole art piece
around it but it seems like he's
combining Helen ly story with Sherman
Fields not realizing that they Spawn
from two separate candy men after the
exhibition two exhibitors who had put on
the event decide to summon him with only
a 1.5c delay on the last mention of the
name good job keeping it efficient
anyway Sherman Fields appears she gets
her throat slashed and he is dragged by
one leg and strangled in midair Fields
also appears to Anthony's girlfriend
Brianna that night in what may or may
not have been a dream and to Anthony
himself the next day where he drops a
razor filled candy in an
elevator going down sir despite this and
learning about the Dead art dealers
Anthony doubles down on his work I'm
expanding the work into a series I'm
opening into a solo
show all about Candyman spread the word
I love that idea that's cuz you're an
idiots Anthony also encourages this art
critic to say candyman's name it's not
clear if he wants her to die or if he's
also just an idiot it's here at the art
critic's apartment where he sees himself
as Candyman in a mirror in a room filled
with bees with his now infected hand on
the same side as candyman's hook we've
seen Candyman appear to his victims
before but we've never seen him appear
as his victims this is a clue that
Anthony is now going down the same path
that Sherman and several others did he's
slowly becoming a Candyman in his own
right he leaves the apartment unscathed
but his friend the art critic is not so
lucky where the Daniel robotti
incarnation of Candyman was associated
with graffiti saying sweets to the Sweet
the Sherman Fields version would leave
behind a different phrase say my name
which was also the title of Anthony
McCoy's art piece this is also the
message left behind when four teenagers
recite the Candyman name in the school
bathroom and find themselves locked in
and massacred one by one by the way the
dramatic pause on this one is 4 seconds
the recent string of tragedies does seem
to put a spotlight on Anthony's art a
similarity that he shares with Daniel
Roby whose paintings were preserved
after his death which we will get back
to my board members are buzzing about
McCoy's work okay enough with the be
puns lady Anthony visits his mom who is
squeamish around the mere mention of the
word candyman he finds out she lied
about where he was from to protect him
from Cabrini Green and the threat of
being slashed open by an evil spirits
hook still he decides to return to what
remains of the old neighborhood to
ReDiscover his past meanwhile his
girlfriend is looking for him and gets
locked in the dry cleaning area at the
laundromat and abducted by William who
essentially Has Come To Worship the idea
of Candyman and thinks the community
needs a new Candyman as a means of
coping with the injustices of their
world or something but a story like that
a pain like that last
ever that's candy man Anthony's right
hand has become more and more infected
after the beasting which spreads to the
rest of his body and to speed up the
transformation William cuts off his hand
and replaces it with a hook planning to
frame him and get him killed by police
so that he can Legend dies as the next
Candyman and live forever through the
stories that are passed down and sure
enough when the cops show up they
immediately strike down Anthony who is
just lying defenseless in his
girlfriend's arm there are a lot of
things that have to happen perfectly for
William's plan to work and they do
happen pausing for context the way
things worked out play on this idea of
Candyman being a cycle of events rather
than one singular story preserved over
the years Daniel robai was a victim of
prejudice around interracial
relationships and each of the next three
candymen were victims of racism that
reflected their time period Candyman
2021 came out in drum roll please 2021
which was one year after George Floyd
was a notable victim of police brutality
so Anthony's death is emblematic of the
era there was also another notable
police brutality victim earlier that
year named Briana Taylor and there was
this social media movement using the
hash say her name in order to put
pressure on the police department to
properly investigate the incident this
is almost certainly the inspiration for
candyman's new motto say my name and
maybe even the reason that Anthony's
girlfriend is named Briana spelled
differently but pronounced the same as
Briana Taylor especially considering
what's about to happen next after
Anthony is shot one of the cops on the
scene tries to get Briana to change her
story to save the other officer's
reputation instead of playing his game
she uses his rearview mirror to utter
the Candyman name four times but we
don't have to wait to see how long she
pauses before the final one because the
cop finishes the job for her Candyman
this summons the newest iteration of the
Candyman which appears at first to be
Anthony but he's got some familiar lines
I am the writing on the walls I am the
sweet smell of Blood on the street the
buzz that echoes in the Alleyways they
will say I shed innocent blood you are
far from Innocent but they will say you
were that's all that matters he takes
revenge on two of the cops on the scene
as more and more bees swarm around him
completely engulfing his head he slashes
the third and final cop against the
brick wall in the old Cabrini Green and
levitates before Briana but when the
swarm of insects finally disperses she
finds herself staring into the face of
Daniel robati the original Candyman who
is finally back
H everyone we obviously haven't seen it
go down like this before as far as we
know when Sherman Fields came came back
as a vengeful Spirit he still looked
like himself I imagine the reason that
Anthony merged with Daniel Roby is
because he brought candyman's name back
to prominence through ART just as robati
originally made a name for himself
through ART could it also have something
to do with Anthony being kept Alive by
robai 27 years ago sure we have no idea
what the actual reason is and it's never
explained but Cy isn't it kind of your
job to explain it yeah but we literally
have nothing to go off of so all I can
do is provide a few ideas which I did
what I do know is that robati seems to
be weak here now that he's back and
requires the will and cooperation of his
victim more than ever it's been a long
time but he hasn't forgotten about being
bested by Annie tant all those years ago
and she's his first known victim in the
2020s but not before passing some advice
onto her daughter just 2 hours before
Candyman got to her You Must Destroy the
myth as long as people believe as long
as they call his name he will always
come back Annie's death was ruled as a
suicide and Caroline now an adult the
last remain remaining member of her
family is the sole survivor of robotized
bloodline it wouldn't be long before she
had her own brush up against the old
family tree but when exactly does this
happen I had to get a little creative to
figure it out so remember how I said
weekdays in the Candyman world don't
match up with weekdays in our world
because on Anthony's computer we see
that the date is Tuesday May 15th 2019
but in our world May 15th is on a
Wednesday so the day of the week in
Candyman will always be one day earlier
well in Candyman Day of the Dead we hear
this Saturday's Day of the Dead Day of
the Dead begins on November 1st I made
calendars with the adjusted weekdays of
the Candyman universe and found four
possible dates where Day of the Dead
falls on Saturday in their world
November 2015 November 2020 November
2026 and November 2037 now if you'll
recall Caroline was born in 1995 at the
end of Candyman farewell to the flesh so
in 2015 she would be 20 years old in
2020 she would be 25 years old in 2026
she would be 31 years old and in 2037
she would be 42 years old the actress
who plays Caroline in candy Day of the
Dead was 31 years old at the time it
came out so it would appear that it
takes place in 2026 I have noticed a
couple websites claiming that it's 25
years after farewell to the flesh
however I am going to stick with the
evidence that is actually in the movies
anyway Caroline's friend Miguel is
holding an art gallery in LA to show off
the works of Daniel Roby which Caroline
has inherited she wants people to
appreciate Daniel Roby the artist not
exploit him for being at the center of
the Candy Man meth Miguel understands
marketing a little better than she does
that for example I easily could have
marketed this video as what Dan roboty
taught us about urban legends and
interracial relations a video essay and
gotten like 15 views but I didn't do
that thankfully but Miguel's promotional
genius ends up bringing in a little bit
more of an unsavory crowd and things get
a little out of
[Music]
hand as Miguel tells his audience about
robot's origin story we see the scene of
him tied to a tree where his body is
ravaged by bees at night whereas before
it appeared to be during the day and he
was on the ground you could look at this
as a continuity error but again I choose
to see it as an example of the nature of
urban legends it's like the telephone
game I mentioned previously details get
changed as it's passed from generation
to generation I choose to see the
depiction featured in Candyman 2
farewell to the flesh is what actually
happened because Annie seems to receive
this Vision directly from Candyman
whereas the depiction in Candyman 3 Day
of the Dead is shown while an art dealer
is attempting to tell candyman's story
or at least the version of the story
that he's heard what we see here is just
a vis ual representation of that at one
point during the evening Miguel dares
Caroline to prove that she doesn't
believe in Candyman by calling his name
into the mirror she pauses a modest 3
seconds before completing the ritual but
she and the other guests are terrified
when the mirror breaks and a hook-handed
man storms into the gallery this turned
out to only be an actor that Miguel had
hired for the event but the curse that
she brought upon herself was real but
nothing Supernatural would happen until
that night also I'm not really sure what
Miguel was trying to do here it doesn't
seem like having a raving lunatic
apparently crash your gallery would help
you sell more artwork maybe he's not the
marketing genius that I made him out to
be that evening on the subway candyman's
voice Echoes through the tunnels and she
sees a swarm of bees approach as he
floats in her Direction and gives her
the usual Spiel
believe in me believe please don't tell
me that's another pun please anyway
Caroline passes out but the activity for
that evening continues he goes after
Miguel and his dates a model who is
literally smearing honey on herself with
a honeycomb you're just begging Candyman
to kill you at that point which he does
of of course Miguel getss the old Hook
and the model is stung by bees and it
appears she might have gotten the sharp
end of the hook as well but I obviously
can't show that but I will showed the
message that he left behind on the wall
believe this has been candyman's main
goal for a while now it's been 136 years
since this Legend began and despite
there being evidence of his existence it
seems like nobody really believes in him
or fears him anymore it actually
reminded me a lot of the episode that I
did on Freddy Krueger as the years go by
people stop being afraid and these
entities need people to believe in them
in order to maintain their powers we
even saw something Sim similar with
Pennywise in it chapter 2 I guess I'm
finding that this is a pretty common
Trope in the horror genre and honestly
this idea of belief giving an entity
power could be rooted in reality if you
recall at the beginning of this video I
discussed Bloody Mary and how some
people who performed the ritual actually
believe that they did see her in the
mirror because they believe that they
would see her in a sense she's literally
only appearing to those who believe
belief is her power Caroline eventually
discovers Miguel and a Duo of comically
racist cops gets on the case here's a
highlight reel your kind's always up to
something get back to your business
Miguel he goes and gets himself killed
like like you said Jamal wants to go
shoot some
hoops long story short the paintings
from the art gallery were all stolen on
the night of Miguel's death and his
friends David the actor who he had hired
to crash the gallery is a possible
suspect so he and Caroline team up to
retrieve the paintings and clear David's
name but Caroline starts seeing more and
more evidence of her great great great
grandpa robai being more than just a
doubted men she steps into the bathroom
while David is asking her around for
info at a bar where a Candyman appears
and shows her imagery of her dead mother
our story shall be one one destiny one
family one blood and I can't decide if
that comes off more like a Bob Marley
lyric or more like a religious
passage yeah now that I think about it
one love does have religious lyrics and
it's just my own fault that I associate
more with a tropical beach but just the
way that Candyman talks he uses a lot of
words that you might expect to find in a
religious text the word blood can just
as easily refer to violence or sacrifice
as it can to family connections and
Bloodlines Caroline is supposedly the
last survivor of his bloodline and he's
trying to get her to join with the rest
of their family in death so in this case
it kind of refers to both this time
Caroline freaks out having accepted the
existence of the family Phantom of fudgy
and fruity snacks so David takes her to
see his grandmother a curandera or a
Healer of evil spirits in some Latin
American cultures she tells him that
evil cannot exist without good but her
visions of Candyman are getting worse as
she sees a bee crawl out from a bloody
red spot in the egg Yol in this ritual
the egg is basically supposed to sweep
up any bad mojo that might be attached
to her in another video I think I
described it as the spiritual equivalent
of a paper towel picking up dirt off a
surface in order to cleanse the subject
I think it's probably the first time
we've seen anyone do anything to try to
detach themselves from Candyman after
saying his name in the mirror it's a
good idea but it doesn't work and
Caroline asked David to stay with her
until her roommate gets home so she
doesn't have to be alone this of course
leads to them going to bed together but
at some point during this encounter
David is replaced with Daniel that is
Daniel roiti it was one thing when he
was trying to kiss Helen Lyle in 1992
but dude this is your great great great
granddaughter like that's kind of weird
I don't really like it I think the
significance is supposed to be that
there's an intimacy subtext because
Caroline mckever is named after Caroline
Sullivan his lover from when he was
alive but this is just a little less
Louisiana and a little more Alabama if
you catch my drift he tells her that
he'll let David live only if she takes
his place and becomes his victim
basically the same offer that he made to
Helen Lyle allowing her to be the victim
instead of the baby Anthony but this
time it's reversed David has a young
daughter who would be orphaned if
something were to happen to him once
again Caroline passes out and her
roommate eventually finds her in the
midst of a nightmare when she wakes up
she's spouting off about how Candyman
has taken David but from Tamara's point
of view it looks like she's lost it I'm
not crazy I didn't say you were crazy
but you need to talk to somebody you
just need some help yeah I didn't say
you were crazy you just need to talk to
a professional because you're crazy
Candyman does have a way with making his
victims look mentally unwell he did the
same thing to Helen who got locked up in
an asylum because of it and to a lesser
extent he made Anthony McCoy look like
he'd gone off the deep end too you may
have noticed at this point that this
feels contradictory if he wants people
to believe in him then why make his
victims look crazy it's working against
his main goal would you be more likely
to believe a ghost story from a crazy
person or a sane person this is probably
the single biggest struggle that I had
while crafting my analysis of this
character his actions don't seem to
match up with his stated intention at
the end of the day we don't have any
explanation for this I'm just left to
assume that there's some kind of rule
preventing him from providing hard
evidence to get people to believe in him
or maybe he only benefits from their
belief in him if they don't actually
have proof that he exists one thing I
kept coming back to is the security tape
of him taking out the police officer in
1995 shouldn't this have gotten a whole
bunch of people to believe in him well
after going over all of my Candyman
notes I think I may have found the
answer
one theme that has come up over and over
throughout candyman's sorted history is
the comparison of how people see him as
an urban legend and how devotees
interact with religion from his clothing
to his sermon likee monologues to the
many other references and religious
subtexts that I've pointed out in this
video I think the lack of definitive
evidence provided to make people believe
in him operates the same way as religion
religion is all about faith followers of
a religion may have a relationship with
God but it's never in the form of
irrefutable proof that God exists is
because that wouldn't be faith that
would just be like proof it reminds me
of this old meme pointing out how God is
always intervening talking to prophets
creating Miracles and delivering
messages to mankind but then after the
invention of the video camera he just
never shows up again obviously it's just
a meme it's just a joke I think you can
believe in God even if you don't see the
biblical stories as literal events that
happened but the main point that I'm
getting at here is that those who
believe do so even without proof and the
point behind Candyman is that urban
legends and Supernatural hook-handed
Killers operate very much the same way
the mystery around the whole thing
creates Believers whether it be Candyman
Bloody Mary the hookman or any other
urban legend and this is what gives
power to those Legends and this would
also kind of explain why Candyman likes
to have one victim in each movie that he
keeps alive for most of it he wants
Caroline to believe in him and fear Him
and it is her faith that will inspire
others to do the same and this is pretty
much how it goes in every installment of
Candyman so Caroline situation goes very
much like Helen's did in '92 he kills
her roommate just as he kills
bernardette this gets Caroline arrested
did just as Helen was arrested then he
kills the police officer holding her
captive just as he killed the
psychiatrist who kept Helen captive
Caroline is giving the officers keys so
she can escape just as Helen's
restraints were cut loose so that she
could escape with nowhere else to go
Caroline goes to David's house and gets
Another Blessing from his grandmother
who elaborates on the advice from
earlier she says evil cannot exist
without good and she must destroy good
in order to destroy evil this doesn't
seem like very good advice and Caroline
interprets it to mean that she has to
destroy the paintings of Caroline
Sullivan she evades the police by
blending through the Day of the Dead
celebration taking place in the streets
and Candyman tries to convince her to
give herself up to him along the way to
her finally locating the gangsters who
stole Daniel robot's artwork this new
metal basist looking guy claims that the
paintings are haunted and he wants her
to take them away but oh no it's a trap
she gets knocked out by a golf dude with
a hook Caroline's got it pretty rough
okay she gets knocked out like every 20
minutes she awakes to what appears to be
a Marilyn Manson cover band but soon
finds out that it's actually not that at
all this this is essentially candyman's
cult gathered to perform a ritual to
honor him for the Day of the Dead this
is the result of the religious figure
aura that he's given off for his entire
afterlife he now has followers
performing ceremonies in his honor even
if they are trying way too hard to sound
edgy we had an epiphany at the gallery
his myth called to
us a reflection of the evil that created
you make sure you subscribe for new
Horrors every week otherwise I'll feel
[__] empty inside one of these
Antichrist Superstars gets the honor of
summoning him in a broken mirror taking
a 5-second dramatic pause at the end
when he shows up he does a lot of damage
ripping out the piercings of the leader
before slashing his neck and presumably
doing the same to all or most of the
others he makes one last offer to
Caroline proposing to let David live in
exchange for her life and overwhelmed by
his presence I guess even though she's
seen him six times before this she
passes out again maybe it's time to see
someone about about that you need to
talk with somebody you just need some
help and she wakes up she finds a hook
and discovers the paintings of Candyman
seemingly guarded by thousands of beads
but before she can find the courage to
approach she's distracted when she spots
David still alive but hanging on a pair
of industrial hooks Bobby D style since
he is still alive I'll assume that
there's no issue with me showing this
footage but as she tries to save him
Candyman appears one last time and kind
of confirms what I was theorizing about
earlier about him seeing Caroline as a
metaphorical standin for his Caroline At
Last I will have what was taken from me
so many many years
ago my
dignity my destiny my blood and he
kisses her or maybe she kisses him just
goes to show that some things are better
not kept in the family but it is
actually Caroline's family that pulls
her out of this she has a vision of her
dead mother causing her to change her
tune climb through the swarm of bees and
destroy the paintings of robai and his
girlfriend with iron ically a hook the
tool that Candyman used to rip apart so
many of his countless victims she also
knocks over some candles setting the
whole display on fire just as Candyman
was set a blaze all of those years ago
burning the paintings also sets his
Spirit on fire and he burns in agony
once
more and Caroline feels that she has
finally ended the 136 Year Legacy of the
Candyman they all blame someone else for
your crimes I destroyed you you're good
and you're evil there's nothing left
there's no proof of your existence I
destroyed the myth no one will ever call
your name again which honestly has got
to be the most stupid and naive thing
ever because there is literally graffiti
all over the place in multiple cities
depicting the Candyman not to mention
the book that was written by purcel
countless news articles but most
importantly multiple Generations telling
the tale via oral tradition there's no
way you could possibly wipe out a myth
like Candyman and even attempting to do
so would most likely have a strand
effect and bring even more attention to
him police show up on the scene shortly
after after and you know that this means
that there'll be reports filed and this
will end up on the internet and just fan
the fire of Candyman rumors it seems
like if you truly wanted to neutralize
Candy Man the best way to go about it
would be through narrative drift for
example if you intentionally spread a
bunch of rumors saying you only have to
say the name three times then that'll
probably end up getting spread around
and a decent amount of people will
believe it I mean saying the name three
times works for bloody mary Beetlejuice
and biggy small so it seems kind of
believable there reminds me of this cor
post I saw one time that said what would
happen if you said Candyman Beetle Juice
Bloody Mary three times in a mirror and
the person who answered it was just like
absolutely nothing none of these beings
even exist like not even entertaining
the fun part of the question but yeah
your best bet would just be to
intentionally change the legend over
time so that it no longer resembles the
original story or just not acknowledge
it like what Ethan Trant tried to do but
at the end of the day it takes more than
one person to do either of those things
which means the legend will probably
always persist in some form so does that
mean that we haven't actually seen the
last of the Candyman maybe but
personally I think his story has been
told there's not a whole lot that could
really be added added to it and it's not
really as relevant in a cultural sense
as it was when Candyman was first
created the original Candyman
highlighted how the racial segregation
of the 1890s was still alive in a
different form in the 1990s farewell to
the flesh brought back the idea putting
a spotlight on Octavia who sought to
erase any racial diversity in her family
tree again a pretty subtle theme about
segregation but now as of recording in
the 2020s we're not that far removed
from George Floyd being the biggest
story in the world and we already got a
Candyman movie on the heels of that it
seems kind of like revisiting it again
is just beating a dead horns it's not
like there still aren't bad people in
the world but the original Candyman was
much more of a nuanced commentary
putting a spotlight on how segregation
is still hiding in plain sight and now
it's kind of devolved into very on the-
noose references to literally some of
the biggest news stories in the world
Candyman showed us how a new Legend is
born but what started as a series about
the nature of urban legends and the
intersection of myth and reality has
seemingly become more focused on
reminding us about reality unlike
candyman's many victims I'm not so sure
we need to repeat his name for a fifth
time but to get the full picture on
urban legends what they have to say and
how they've been interpreted in horror
movies I've got a playlist lined up for
you on left with some other great
examples remember to subscribe to C's
world for new Horrors every week ring
the death bell for all notifications and
I will see you in the next one assuming
we both
survive